so we have a bunch of stories to break
down the interview Tucker Carlson uh had
with Vladimir Putin is officially up on
Tucker carlson.com it is a must must
watch there there are some there are
some dry points I must admit the first
half an hour is a history lesson I
literally fell asleep forgive me but I'm
like I'm falling asleep listen it's like
1826 the r the state of Roose and the
the baptism and I'm just like this is
okay Tucker actually caveats the
interview in the beginning saying we
thought he was pattering for time but
there was no time limit to the interview
so he's like I genuinely believe Putin
was expressing his statement that there
is a historical claim to Ukraine we have
and I agree with Tucker and I I I don't
see why anyone in the US anyone in the
west even the government would take a
different view than Tucker did Putin is
explaining that historically Ukraine is
theirs that's basically what he's saying
and that shows motivation for for this
conflict but one of the biggest issues
that we we had uh mentioned leading up
to this interview was whether or not
Tucker Carlson would ask about Evan
gershkovich The Wall Street Journal
reporter who has been in jail for over a
for just about a year turns out Tucker
Carlson not only did ask Putin about
this journalist but actually requested
that Putin release him into his custody
as a sign of good faith to return home
Bravo Tucker Carlson wow and Putin made
the biggest mistake of the night he said
no
he did say a deal could be could be
could be made interestingly he went on
to say that this this 30 I I believe
he's 32 he was caught red-handed with
classified information and he was under
the direction of US Agencies he may be a
journalist but we know who's really
pulling the strings and he was seeking
secret government information
confidential classified information
which basically makes him a spy now I'll
just say this the big narrative leading
up to this interview was that was that
tu Carlson was a mouthpiece for Vladimir
Putin and that Vladimir Putin was going
to lie propagandized to justify his
invasion of Ukraine and not to believe
him the fear was that Tucker Carlson was
giving a platform to a war criminal
imagine how bad it would have been for
the Western media and the Press when
they were forced to report Tucker
Carlson returns home with Evan
gershkovich saving his life from Russian
jail Vladimir Putin agrees in a good
faith effort and Returns the American
journalist home Tucker Carlson would
have taken the headlines across the
board the interview would would become
the biggest bigger than it already is
and it would put everything Putin says
on a pedestal but Putin made that
mistake and he said you know what do I
get out of it we'll think about it Putin
should have just said absolutely Mr
Carlson I want you because then when
Tucker Carlson's plane landed every news
Outlet in the country would have a
reporter waiting at the airport there
would be 10,000 cameras Tucker Tucker
Tucker what happened Evan what's going
on and everything then said in the
interview would be 1,000 fold wow I
think Putin's a straightup extremely
cynical political actor however and if
he was able to get uh for Britney
grinder he traded Victor bout for that
um that was I'm reading it was only in
December uh 2022 so Putin knows he could
get a lot for this journalist and I
think he knows and we're going to be
seeing more of this around the world um
China's going to be doing more of this
or has been doing a lot of this too
we're going to be see a lot see a lot of
this happening in Iran too but
kidnapping and then these Rogue cynical
political regimes trying to exchange
those for political prisoners that are
serving in the US who are actual
criminals I don't believe this Wall
Street Journal um Evan gershkovich um
he's only I think 32 is any sort of spy
journalism is illegal in um Russia so um
I think I need to commend Tucker Carlson
for even asking about this though um I
need to give him credit especially with
all the hype surrounding this interview
and leading up to it um I don't know I
so again right after commenting Tucker I
do have to say though when he did
interview Kanye he did cut out certain
portions I don't know if this is the
full interview that he did conduct I
don't know if in the next couple of
weeks we're going to see a leak of other
footage go down but I wasn't able to see
all of it but from what I saw um I think
Tucker did a a relatively Fair job did
he uh he didn't bring up Snowden at all
did he no I don't think so I think so
that's kind of been under the radar
Snowden over in Russia also uh what's
her name that accused Joe Biden of
sexual assault Tera re T Reed she's in
Russia I don't want to deril she fled to
Russia yeah she's there now she just did
an interview with uh God who was it was
it Ivory Hecker did interview with
somebody I'm I can't believe Putin
didn't just say yeah yeah that would
have been truly epic and I don't think
he had considered that well he could get
so much for it he got Victor B no but
but I understand what you're saying
that's he got The Merchant of death for
a WNBA player I mean it's crazy but just
think about I mean in this interview
which we and we'll get into this in
Greater detail he said that he
approached Bill Clinton about joining
NATO and that Clinton said yeah actually
yes but then later that night came back
and said you know what we talked about
it no it's not going to happen the there
were there were key narrative points
Putin clearly wants to be heard unless
you know what to be honest maybe he does
not care at all one way or another what
the American people think I I imagine
that as the president of a country that
is currently at war with the West he
would want to propagandize the West as
much as possible to shatter sentiment
any favor towards funding and supporting
Ukraine which is actually just NATO War
efforts and that's how you do it what
value do you get from some Wall Street
Journal guys he is one dude but you
could amplify the power of that
interview so you know I I think
ultimately for for the United States
it's a good thing Putin misstepped here
and didn't do these things when it comes
to the propaganda he did say in the war
of propaganda it is very hard to defeat
the United States they control all the
media like he knows what he's up against
and I also think when it comes to the
Wall Street Journal journalist he
probably doesn't want to show like
weakness you probably see it as weakness
to give into an interview and say like
I'll release someone just because Tucker
Carlson has oh I disagree you think so
strength you think it's strength for him
to be like okay since Tucker brought it
up it'll be good it'll look good for me
publicly to release someone instead of
doing on his own coition absolutely if
like the good faith of you coming here
is enough is all I you have come to me
to allow me to speak to you and those
who follow you to share the views that
we have knowing that our countries do
not agree for your efforts I will
release to you Evan gershkovich and I'm
telling you like every journalist would
have 10 photographers waiting at the
airport as the plane is landing all the
cameras are going to be filming it from
every possible angle it would have been
the biggest story in the world to be
fair it probably already is the biggest
story but it would been substantially
larger and and it's I imagine the worst
thing for the West that Tucker Carlson
not only shared Putin's narrative but
that Putin showed to be amicable imagine
coming back and saying and Tucker saying
they are lying to you about the position
of Vladimir Putin and why he's at war in
Ukraine they are lying to you about who
he is he has even as a sign of good
faith released to us this reporter
Putin's bad at what he does I mean he's
really good at a lot of things does but
this was his massive opportunity I I I'm
surprised he didn't say yes the backlash
to the interview though is like did no
one watch the Oliver Stone stuff it
didn't happen that long ago and like you
get the same feeling he's a he's a
Charming intelligent guy whether you
like him or not like he's good at
interviews I think he rehashed to that
he is a Russian irid dentist and I know
it's cliche to say at this point but he
does believe that the collapse of the
Soviet Union was the biggest like
geopolitical strategy and he was a part
ofure failure and one of the well
depends on who you ask um so I do think
he's still cynically thinking about
these things he's wants as much of
Ukraine as he's going to be able to take
and if there is a ceasefire in Ukraine
I'm sure down the line he'll be
interested in taking another bite of it
and if there's any part of NATO that
collaps with Estonia and lvia um I'm
sure he'd want to take a chunk of those
too because again he sees those as a
part of Russia um all of the former USSR
so uh it's bad and dangerous and I and I
think we need to be more cleare eyed
about the threat he poses but I can also
give you one very very obvious
reasonable reason why he did not release
this person it's very easy for us on the
surface to say look at the political PR
opportunity the other reality is that
Evan gershkovich actually has very
serious classified information in his
brain oh that's true that simply by
speaking to the ca would compromise the
security position of Russia so he will
never be released yeah I see it is
possible I think for a journalist to be
over there and be a spy we know there
spies they've been infiltrated over here
for years you know it it's definitely
possible I don't think they have free
speech of free media in Russia though
but but it's the it's the you know it's
the subliminal the Lial and the super
Lial right the sub liim the super Lial
being like an American reporter working
in Moscow just quite literally reporting
whatever is going on making sure that
information comes to the American public
that's the that's the on in your face
then you have people who like maybe at
one point worked for an industry or
whatever and they're over there and they
learn things and they post on social
media but the subliminal is like under
the surface one way or another reporting
to a US agenc to deliver information and
so you know when we have like uh shinua
or RT or Sputnik these are just regular
journalists uh to be fair like shinua
they're reporting to the Chinese
Communist party so like there's no
really you know there are they're spies
but their work is above board it's super
Lial it's like they're quite literally
saying whatever you tell me I'm going to
share with China and the chines
Communist party but we do have spies
probably sneaking across the southern
border right now for China and uh we
know it's happening so for this to
happen I I got to be honest when they
announced something like a reporter got
arrested my immediate thought is not oh
no they've they've arrested an innocent
journalist they must be evil my immedate
thought is like interesting I need to
hear more about this because innocent
till proven guilty I I don't I don't
trust Vladimir Putin but at the same
time I don't see him creating this kind
of problem and PR problem unless unless
it means something yeah the the arrest
of gers uh uh gershkovich means that
people in the states are going to be
aggressive towards Russia and he knows
that so there there's there's there's a
reason and uh I'll say it again you know
on the surface I'm saying it was an
opportunity to release him I wonder if
gershovich actually learned something so
serious that he cannot be allowed to
speak to uh to the
Americans or to the West in general that
would be crazy I mean I probably I like
the part where Putin says uh Tucker asks
who blew up the nordstream and Putin
goes you did he goes Tucker goes I was
busy that day
and then Putin says the CI didn't have
an alibi CIA CIA yeah Cia didn't have an
alibi who else could sink to the bottom
of the Baltic Sea this is uh this is an
interesting one this is from the same
interview Putin slams us and Bill
Clinton for deceiving Russia over NATO
membership as he trashes Biden Praises
Trump and warns there no there's no
stopping his supersonic missile system
this is interesting Putin says that Bill
Clinton offered Russia a place in NATO
but was overruled by his staff so
basically what happens is Putin was like
look in the 90s I meet with Bill Clinton
and there's pictures of it Tucker posts
picture includes pictures in the
interview and I said look if Russia
wants to join NATO would that be
possible and Bill Clinton said I think
so yeah and then comes back later that
night for dinner whatever I think that's
what he said and Clinton says you know
we talked about it it's not going to
happen Putin said the reason was the US
applies pressure on all the NATO member
states and they vote the way the US
wants having some a nation as powerful
as Russia as large would mean that US
influence would be compromised to a
certain degree within
NATO I'll say outright that is Vladimir
Putin's propaganda on this look I'll
tell you first and foremost obviously
the US exerts the most influence over
NATO especially when we're footing out
the bills but also his reason for why he
got kicked out of the club I'm not going
to take it at 100% I think there's some
truth to it but he's giving you the I'm
always the good guy
narrative yeah I mean in terms of the
nordstream stuff did you see that this
was a while back but the New York Times
had a headline that was like it's better
that we don't get the truth yeah it's
better that we don't know that that
headline was the creepiest one it's New
York Times um oh you're looking for the
recent stuff yeah but it's just bizarre
I mean Biden just point blank said that
we did it basically thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.net